[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time i'm rhett and i'm
linked this week at the round table of
dim lighting we're looking back
at the year through the lens of our
online purchases because after all
that's how we define ourselves anyway
right that's how i do
no i
i this was a lot of fun last year when
we did it and i think that you
you expand you've already pre-expanded
because we said this would be our amazon
purchases i totally forgot because
because we get so many things through
amazon
uh so i've kind of limited it to to
those purchases
but i know you've you're going outside
of that i had to and so i i reserved the
right to maybe go outside of that a
little bit because i did make some
significant purchases that were not on
amazon but whatever you need to fully
define yourself that's what this is
about well you know i uh unless you buy
things how do you know who you are
well how do you know
my my i've discovered that my sort of
calling in life
is to go into the driveway and to break
down boxes oh and flatten them and put
them into recycling like that that's my
me time because i try to get my kids to
do it and they won't you know i'm a
failed father because i think yeah i
think last year my list was um
that special box cutter which i'd
recommended yeah was on my list and uh
we had to pick up something we had to
pick up a mirror that wouldn't every
time it was delivered to the house it
was broken so christy arranged for us to
pick it up from the shop
and then we got there and i took my box
cutter with me because i'm like i want
to open it there and i want to do it
with my box cutter and they're like yeah
you don't have to open it here because
then
well you it's you can't you have to
return in the packaging and i was like
no we're opening it here and i'm using
my box cutter
i could tell they were really eyeing it
they liked the slice
um it was broken by the way your boss
cutter was broken
no the mirror was broken oh which is and
so we didn't we still didn't get it
um mirrors break man that's one of those
one of the hazards
i'm not going to go better on their dime
than ours i'm going to go through a lot
of stuff and more stuff than you
undoubtedly i'm going through everything
i bought but i'm not going through my
exhaustive list
because that's 141 individual items
just for me
now i want you to understand
the vast majority of these are very
small inconsequential and i'll get into
some of those
uh it would just why are you apologizing
no i'm just saying it would be so well
because people are like it's i know
people have lots of opinions about
buying stuff on amazon to begin with i
get it i understand
i think in the end we're gonna figure
this out and i think that the
convenience of the service is gonna be
something that we find a way to do
without qualm but i will say that
that comes out to like almost almost
buying something every other day you
know
but
not buying multiple things in one
shipment but still there's ends up being
a lot of boxes
so there's i do there's a little bit of
guilt there's a little bit of guilt
associated with this
uh i'm just saying that up front but i
mean
the place i i wanted to start just
because there's literally one two three
four five six seven eight
eight items in just this one journey and
this is just for me this doesn't count
the ones that jesse got oh you're
starting i was going to start with a
journey okay
okay
who's got the better journey it sounds
like you've got a longer journey mine's
simple
and that is the journey to to acquire
the correct face mask
oh uh-huh and this is something that is
especially
the reason that this is so personal to
me is that
it has to do with the beard
right
so early on in the pandemic
when we started wearing masks a lot i
started realizing that i was getting
masked beard
and it's it can get so pronounced i
don't know if you remember when we were
practicing um the live stream that day
and we wore masks during the live
live stream like rehearsal yeah
and
i took it off to show everybody what my
mask beard looks like and like paisley
got a profile shot of me which we can oh
are you sure you want to show that you
know what i'm not going to show no it's
being shot no no i'm not showing already
happening there's a there is so many
shots of me out there without a beard i
don't have to show the mask beard i
don't have to do it i reserve the right
to not show the mask i already saw it
they haven't seen it it's over i'm
making the call we're not showing it you
really looked it up and they just saw it
oh you know what you can tweet it on
your personal account they're seeing it
again um
wow so
because the mask and here's the thing
about massbeard it's not just that the
masked beard looks bad
it's that oh it looks yeah we can tell
it looks bad we're looking at it a third
time it locks in
like you put a curling iron
and like i you can't get rid of it
unless you stop
and you wash your beard with shampoo and
then let it dry like you can't shampoo
your beard you can yeah i mean
in order to get the when it's that
locked in it will not it's like it's
like you curled your hair and you can't
get rid of it it's like you don't have a
beard
you just have a you just have hair for
skin
against your face and then there's a
line and then there's something hanging
down there like a curtain
yeah we're looking at it a fifth time
so
the problem is is that they make these
masks that are
that are supposed to cover your whole
beard uh-huh yeah and
i try i tried a few of these man
i'm gonna go through the what all the
masks so i started with
the bio th
face mask
which is this is just like that
makes it kind of like a duck build it's
an n95 it's a dispose 85 yeah
yeah k 95 k95 or whatever it is pointy
uh and i was like how this is causing
trouble so then i did the michelle
xl summer face and beard summer face
headwear reusable cloth covering for
dust outdoors
first of all
lots of cloth masks early on in the
pandemic before we really understood
that those are not very effective yeah
but that was a whole year earlier uh
well this is well i'm still no but the
whole
the cloth is not really working that
well
that knowledge was really dispensed in
2021 it wasn't really dispensed in 2020.
when we all kind of came to terms with
the fact that i think you it was more of
a 2021 thing for you because it was more
you were more of getting out
we were we were becoming more active and
need masks more and trying to settle
online a lot more math what is going to
right and this is before i was like okay
i'm still trying these masks that are
probably not even effective because now
you're making a public decision yeah not
just a protective decision
there's a look here then i did
the toltecs face mask
then the purine face mask adult xl
extra-large for men with beards
then
the craft and soul matana face mask
then the innerplex youth adult three-ply
phase okay so now i'm getting back into
like this is i this is the point where i
abandoned
i'm like just trying to cover the whole
beard it's not a tight thing it's just
i'm i'm not wearing a mask just to make
it look like i'm wearing a mask which is
what a lot of people do who don't even
believe that the masks work even though
they clearly do if they're one right and
it's the right kind of mask
some people are just like i'm complying
with your
idea here or your rules
but i'm trying to make it as easy as
possible but i was like i actually i'm
actually interested in doing this in an
effective way so i abandoned the beard
mask because it's just not gonna happen
it's kind of like you're gonna when you
wear a hat
you're not gonna then
if you're out with people just take the
hat off and then walk around with hat
head you're committing you're just going
to have to wear the mask all the time
right and then
i got this outdoor research essential
face mask kit a kit it's it's just build
your own these are the words that they
use
and then again and then finally i just
landed on disposable face mask
[Laughter]
and i gave up
yeah and that's and so now i operate
with two two distinct choices there is
the the the k95 or kn-95 whatever it is
which is what we have here at the studio
for everybody to wear that was on my
list of something that i and that's what
we buy a lot of and that that and that
locks it in and that does give me mask
beard
and then i've got this the surgical mask
like the three-ply surgical mask which
is effective at catching droplets but it
sits more on top of the beard and
doesn't create like if i'm like if i'm
doing if jesse and i are going out and
we have to
wear the mask into the restaurant but
then when we sit down we take the mask
off to eat so it's kind of like we're
wearing a mask just to say that we wore
a mask or just because they made us wear
a mask and we went in i believe in mass
but when you're going into a restaurant
to eat you're not really accomplishing
anything by wearing the mask as you walk
to your table okay i'm taking a risk at
that point
but in that case i don't want to have
mass beard on my date so then that's
when i just wear the surgical one that
kind of sits right on top and that i can
kind of deal with that masked beard so
you yeah but there was an eight point
assist there was an eight-point mass
journey and that didn't even include the
stuff that jesse was buying
it was he went all over the place okay
my j you want to know my version of that
journey
is
with garden hoses
so in a moment you're trying to wash the
virus off your face with a garden hose
yeah he's like i don't wear a mask but i
wash my face every day well i will
constantly i'm constantly blasting my
face with a garden house the fires can't
get in there you just go right in here
and it comes out your nose
uh
it turns out it's really hard to find a
garden hose that's worth a damn that's
true man uh i was looking back through
the list and i was just so shocked i was
like okay
i got an expandable garden hose because
you don't want i don't want one that you
got to like loop up and you know all of
the all the problems with like where's
it gonna be stored and how and
how big is it and how on
it just doesn't cooperate with i went on
this journey in 2020 by the way
did you talk about it i don't think i
don't know if i did why didn't i land
okay i i had it i went because i bought
it for the hardware store it was
expandable
and then what would happen is it was
like black and it would scrunch up so at
the moment that all the
liquid came out of it it would shrink up
like like cold wiener and then a cold
winter be very easy to store but then
when that thing gets plump again
when it's
shooting out all that water it's it's
spurting out of every place it's it's
it's cracking leaks all over the place
just like a penis and i will tell you
that like we bought the ones that said
oh 100 guaranteed and then what are you
supposed to do they break they they
break they don't don't just break and
sometimes we bought three and they were
all like they just split in the middle
and like oh there's just a whole section
you can't get an expandable so then we
were so angry
that we bought a flex steel like we went
to the opposite extreme it it's like a
chrome
it's like a it's just a pipe it's a
it's just a pipe on a hinge
you can't but it doesn't bend at all it
did bend it would it would bend up but
it was like it's not gonna leak now i
can only i can only water in this exact
radius but it will never leak
what we did and you know honestly
christie's the one who bought it it's
like christy looked at those leaky
wieners and she said i'm going medieval
on your ass like literally i'm buying
the armored version
of a garden hose this is the one from
the infomercial um it's just called flex
steel i think there's an infomercial for
it not flex seal that's an infomercial
that's for the boats no no i know it's
not when you want to cut chop a boat in
half and then because there's also
infomercials for the expandable ones too
that's where i fell in love with the
idea um
and then we ended up with
uh
it's called a no kink but it's like it's
made of different stuff than expandable
so it's kind of expandable yeah i can't
go there it's called no kink you got to
go you gotta go kink
so uh it's still kinks
yeah because you listen garden you can't
help you can't help but kink something
there is i mean
there's got to be an answer
and i still haven't found it i gave up
with the third one it's not leaking yet
but it is kinking even though it's
called the no kink well i don't have a
record of this because again i went to
the hardware store for uh because i do
shop local okay i believe in that um i
went to the hardware store to get
we we actually decided on a hose that is
not expandable but per se but like it
gets really really it doesn't shrink up
but it's super like flexible that that's
what we have and they're black yes it's
called the no kink okay well i've got we
have that's what we have we have three
of those or four maybe that one in the
house and
um
i bought the the things to to to wind it
up not not not to like crank it wind it
up but just like this thing that sits on
the side of the house and we just roll
it over christy wants to get like a
piece of pottery that i can just shove
it down like a snake like a decorative
cobra coming out of it well you have
pieces you have to play an instrument to
get the snake get this the hose to come
out that's the problem with it break out
my recorder
we are dating so hard
move on to something else um
okay
garden hoses man who who would have
thought okay i'm gonna now i'm going in
chronological order and this again this
is just the stuff that i thought was
notable i bought this first name because
of you
the
neomed
special link
inhaler
what
sign inhaler natural non-medicated
aromatherapy inhaler
so this is like you you're like oh you
come into the office and you you got
some something you put in your nose and
you said it's nif it's a menthol stick
yeah i got it like two years ago maybe
three the thing still works yeah it's
amazing
uh i used it a few seconds ago yeah so
i'm not necessarily i look like
chapstick
but uh
i do i do find because i've got a
slightly deviated septum and the right
nostril will sometimes be like uh it's
not really fully functioning this
morning it's got a little kink in it
that neomed's gonna open you up and uh
and i i do that and i keep it in my bag
and i've used it probably a dozen times
over the past year and it's uh it was a
really good purchase it's super
inexpensive it's kind of like makes you
feel like you're awake
but have you seen this new product
it's all over the internet right now and
if you're on tik tok or instagram you're
getting ads for it if you're me
it's called like um
like something drops like wake up drops
or it's like
i haven't seen this it's caffeinated no
no i think it's smelling salts
i think it's essentially smelling sauce
it's a company that has these things
that you sniff is it
is it
like it's totally like wakes you up i
don't remember the name of it but
everybody i mean i'm getting a bunch of
ads for it because i guess they know
that i want that feeling
i probably toned down from like the the
ones that emt's use i remember when my
mom was would always get her emt
certification there was the smelling
salt today and it's like a little pouch
they would it's kind of like you can get
them on amazon i think when the
policemen get trained in how to use
their their their tasers you get tased
in they get they line up and get tased
well the emts lined up and they got
smell salted
and i was curious and i took one of the
pouches and you you burst it and you
sniff it
and boy that was
that was an awakening well it works man
it was almost totally worth it was
almost painful
and i have to think this is a lesser
version of that because you're not
knocked out well it doesn't knock you
out it brings you back and if you say
but if but but you don't use it when
you're knocked out you use it just when
you feel like if you just there's some
people who swear but you you haven't
tried this you haven't tried this no but
some people swear by smelling salts like
before a workout
it's a trend and so these guys got in on
that yeah
um i'm i'm interested in that
you know that's akin to the to the
neomed
the thing is you don't even use neomed
brand
do you because yours is not neil it was
bought for me and it lasts forever but
it is spelled n-e-i-l yeah i know what
you're talking about
um
we're gonna talk about more products uh
but first we gotta sell you some
products uh were you talking about
mythical.com is that what we're talking
about last chance
what is it
okay we got gift cards yes
that's perfect for the holiday season
kiko
you know it's like you don't know what
to give somebody
but you know that they're a mythical
beast so you give them a mythical gift
gift card and then they can buy whatever
they want with it am i right that's how
that's how gift cards work and we have
them yes we're selling them where
mythical.com of course i love it one of
my favorite things about this stage in
my life is that there are things
happening that you take credit under the
banner of the company that we created
that we are told about that's a good
place to be mythical smelling salts
seems like we're gonna have to push hard
for that one yeah i guess oh man i think
we could get into that the sniffleface
something drops like
horse drops it's not i can't remember
what it is
you got something else suck and wake
um we'll go back and forth we'll go back
and forth until you run out of things
um
i got some smart plugs i committed to
wemo not a sponsor none of this crap is
a sponsor but you buy one smart plug and
then all of a sudden you got all these
other smart plugs and explain this to me
is it it taps into your router yeah and
it's always one app
you have smart lights in your house yeah
but i don't have no internet on them
i do that with the nest
with the with the nest nodes the google
nest interesting yeah these they connect
through your
through your wi-fi and then through your
google home i control them which is the
same thing oh it's not expanding your
wi-fi no no no no no it's just a smarts
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah so the lights
that you i i went to i had a few of
those
and then we did a remodel and like
there's more lights on the outside of
our house and when the electricians came
to do that i said i want all of my plugs
so i guess i'm catching up with you but
i knew when we mow because i already had
some wemo but these are like hardwired
in
so now yeah i do the lutron on that and
you know what i did i didn't get enough
like i still have before i go to bed
there's one light i have to walk to the
front of my house and turn off the
chandelier at the front door
i believe in having at least one manual
light just to stay grounded i feel like
it's done that for me yeah there's one
light that you gotta actually touch
but there's one that doesn't even have a
switch i have to unscrew the bulb every
night
just to feel grounded just shoot it out
with a bb just put in another one
put
in the morning take a little baby gun
out there
shoot it i mean somebody lives like that
justin timberlake apparently wears a new
pair of underwear every single day
really i saw that on one of those
buzzfeed articles 10 years ago
i mean once you start adding the the the
uh
smart light switches to your cart for
every light switch
that's a big car pounding on your that's
a big part
on your wallet yeah so i i just got i
got purchase fright
so i was really excited and then i
didn't get all the ones that i needed
well you can always just get more yeah
but then you got to get somebody to
install them well they say you can do it
yourself but you can but it doesn't have
my picture it's not a neil it doesn't
say neomed on it you know what i'm
saying i know how to put something on my
nose and breathe this is not something
you just smell
therefore
it requires some electrical knowledge if
you gotta if you've gotta go to your
power panel and turn off the power
before you do something yeah that's a
red flag for me being involved i'm
making a call on that one you know it's
like i mean you're just gonna kill
everything in the house well then i
gotta restart everything um i believe
you also got one of these i don't know
if you got the same brand i actually had
to go through two and then i landed on
this one the gista grill press steak
weight burger smasher with wood handle
you stealing my thunder man all the
stuff you've gotten
when you got that early in the year you
didn't tell me no i told you about i
told you about i forgot
like i was on a quest for the perfect
smash burger because it's what my kids
really really like you know i i mean i
like a smash burger and a thick burger i
totally so this is family only earlier
in the year yeah this is like january
and you told me about i totally forgot
well at the end of
i think at the end of 2020 i may have
even talked about it last year i got one
but it wasn't completely flat it was
like it had a ring on it and it had
enough for the burger to like kind of
sneak up in there and you could yes you
could so i was like this is no good i
want one that i can just smash it as
thin as i want
right and when i was
i didn't access this conversation
because yeah it was three months ago
i went and got my burger smasher set
and i you guys set i got i got a gr
first of all for my green egg grill i
got the half moon griddle yeah so that i
could smash the bur you can't do that on
on the um on the grates i just yeah i do
it inside on on in a pan and then
yeah so you got to get the smasher
and you're right it cannot have a lip
so that because then
yeah you want it to be smashed out and
for the edges to be uneven you don't
want it to be a perfect circle yeah and
you got to have the right amount of meat
and you got to measure it out that's
dumb you got to really watch out for
that that's the hottest tip i think
people are going to get today from from
rhett and link
is your burger smasher cannot have a lip
yeah and half of them on amazon even
highly rated ones do
i didn't even put the name brand down
but it wasn't it mine's fully metal
there's no wood because
wood
gets stained in it it looks nicer but
wood doesn't what keeps the heat
from coming into your hand i also do
recommend wearing a glove because it'll
burn the back of your oh yeah you got it
burn all the hairs off your knuckles but
we i mean i've had some in fact that
makes me want to do that this week i've
had some really good
burger times you got to get the smash
right but then this is why
i got the kit because you also have to
have
a shaker
ready with everything you need so like
you smash
and then you shake on your
your
salt and pepper or whatever your mixture
is it definitely needs you want it to be
salty and then when you flip it you flip
it and you saw you shake it again so you
gotta and you
you gotta have a a smasher oh yeah shake
your hand and the grill is so hot that i
gotta do it fast
so so i've got like
a shaker that's b it's big
it's not like you you can't shake on
something and shake on something else
you got to have one shaker that has
everything like uh
the deli style
and it's pretty big so it's it's um you
know like a
three inch you gotta get your ratios
right if you do that but then you're
shaking kind of i'm just doing salt i'm
just doing most mostly salt and a little
bit of pepper yeah and i might put a
little garlic a little bit in in in the
meat
before i mix it
but but you with with my grill and with
the timing and everything and they grill
so fast i'm i can't regulate it like a
stove top so it's like if it gets really
hot you just got to be fast so i don't
have time to be shaking two things well
that's the other thing too
i mean
it's cool to be outside and do it
but i've actually i've i and i've got
like that
nice smoker slash grill that i use for a
lot of things
but i have transitioned to burgers and
steaks inside man i'm doing burgers and
steaks and so i'm doing steak in a pan
you know because i mean if you go to a
fine yeah i just want to you know i just
want to be able to use the grill they're
like they're they're doing it on it well
they're like doing like a broiler but
there's a challenge to it i'm not great
at it because there is timing the third
thing in the kit is
of an extra wide spatula because when
you
when you smash that burger down yeah and
it gets i like to make them really wide
and then you got to have a a real strong
spatch that you can just throw
underneath that thing and then you can
flip it real fast you cheese them on the
grill right cheese them on the grill
yeah and then the other thing they'll
try to sell you in a kit that i opted
out of is a cover
you can kind of to help steam like you
put the
the uh
you flip it salt it put the cheese on it
and then put a cover on it to like
really help it melt but i opted out of
it unnecessary i thought it was
unnecessary okay i would have a good
smash burger
oh so we're going back to you already
because that was me so you know i said
yours was only a smasher
yeah and have the other stuff
and i said yeah i got the same thing no
i i mean i yeah i already had like this
spatula and stuff
i'll go again
um i got a whole category of stuff okay
uh related to
the cat
it's like i you know you get another
type of animal in the house like getting
a second dog was one thing but like
getting
soccer in the house
and then coming to grips with all the
stuff that we needed to do it's like
okay
now there's that chair that he always
sits in there's hair all over that thing
and then
christie's like just scratching it with
her fingernails like there has to be a
way so we got the chomcham
which is like a it's basically like a
lint roller
that um
then it creates a
cat hair
log
that you open the back of it and this
big log of cat hair comes in you feed
that to your dogs and then you feed that
to the dogs no you just feed the cat
[ __ ] to the dogs yeah right um which
brings me to the
the other thing which was multiple
litter boxes
yeah you know it's like we had just the
open cover litter box if you're
a member of the mythical society and
you've and you come to our monthly amas
you you've heard me regale this story of
but i'll tell it
go large here on ear biscuits
jaden is not into this but jasper loves
to eat that cat dookie
gosh it's so gross i don't i'm i'm
embarrassed that i've got something in
my house that can't help but eat cat
[ __ ]
like it i don't know what it says about
me but i feel like it says something
about me that i didn't want to be but if
you had to choose one being in your
house to eat the [ __ ] of another being
in your house you would probably pick
the animals yes and you'd probably go
cat eat doggies catch it that makes me
feel better about it so we're like
trying to get a type of litter box that
saka will still use
but that jasper can't get into
and we went through we got a big bucket
type that like he go he crawls down
inside of it
and then
that was working until
we noticed
that every time
i would go in upstairs into my walk-in
closet in my bedroom that i would smell
some i smelled something that i i
described as
like
a meaty smell
i was like is there something that like
have i worked out and lost a piece of
clothing that has gotten something
growing on it that's like it's a very
deep dark smell
meaty that's almost meaty but like gross
meaty
and then
uh christy discovered that the duffel
bag underneath all of my hanging clothes
in my section of the closet
has been the depository of saka's p
not duki
saka has been crawling into that thing
and just peeing in my duffel bag
again and again and again
and we basically trace that to stress
related to
lily
leaving for college
and him him not being happy
about that
um
i peed in a duffel bag when i was sad so
um
then we had to clean all of that out and
we had to buy this angry orange
detergent just
deterrent is that what i say you didn't
you didn't keep that duffel bag no we
got rid of the
orange detergent on the duffel bag i now
keep on my gym clothes we had to buy
angry orange deterrent to spray on
everything that the cat wasn't supposed
to be
yeah and then so we sprayed in the area
that the duffel bag used to be and then
was very diligent about closing our door
but then is that why you smell like
oranges and that [ __ ] now
[Laughter]
yeah like meaty cat pee yeah but what we
thought was that he wasn't using his
litter box but was instead using my
duffel bag
was because he was he got too big for
the litter box
so then
so now i have this whole purchase
history of like
buying a bigger litter box that he can
jump inside but then he still didn't
want to use that and then when we
switched to a bigger litter box that he
can crawl in the side of that's when
jasper started eating his dookie
and so it's like one problem leads to
another problem he's
so now i'm on the verge of buying
uh
kitty a a litter box that is robotic
that every time jasper comes up it just
scolds him every time the cat poops it's
it scrapes it up and puts it in a place
but then it's like
i don't know the maintenance of that
i don't know there's lots of questions
yeah but you're you're already talking
about how if it's a lot of truly decides
to take the cat with her next year
you're gonna be sad like are you gonna
fight for this cat this conversation is
giving me renewed perspective
because i'm also looking like we bought
a
calming diffuser that
emits the pheromones that a mama cat
puts out to make a make the baby cats
not fight with each other that also
makes cats
chill out
so it's like we're trying to deal with
the cat's stress so that
and then it also attracts the cat to the
area where we want the cat to pee and
not in the duffel bag that's no longer
there so
there's that multiple litter boxes
orange stuff calming diffuser chomchom
hair thing in
a litter genie which is like a fancy
thing that you
as soon as the cat craps you gotta we
scoop up the crap and we put it in a
thing that then it puts it it's like a
diaper genie yeah for cat [ __ ]
so we got i like that i recommend that
you didn't use the robotic one i haven't
gotten haven't gone there yet
okay they're really pricey and i'm also
very i'm very skeptical if saka is going
to go for it or if then he's just going
to start
[ __ ] in the plants
again which was the first problem we had
well i don't have any cat related
purchases
um
i did however
buy 40 large pinky mice
what
oh you're talking about food for a snake
yeah you still have that snake yeah i
mean
he's still he's still a part of the
family moose the snake
um you about 40 40 at a time he said
he's 40 at a time you know he eats one
like one a week
if shepard keeps up with it
um yeah so so i have like a a handful of
mice
in the freezer which jesse isn't happy
about but it's and they're in a bag it's
in another bag
you know there's other animal parts in
our
fridge that we eat it's not that big of
a deal i mean you gotta
why don't you put it in the fridge in
the garage it is in the fridge in the
garage okay that's better um let me i'll
rattle off a couple here uh
sex criminals volume one one weird trick
um what this is a graphic novel how
graphic
um sex criminals
this is a
series
about
a woman who discovers that
when she has an orgasm that time
essentially stops
in the afterglow
and then she meets a man who
after he orgasms the same thing happens
and they can interact with each other
and do things
in the afterglow
uh
this is a famous graphic novel or comic
book were you googling that that you
discovered this um
i was googling
uh can i stop time with my orgasms yeah
i was like yeah hi
why does it feel like time has stopped
after no uh i was googling
highly rated graphic novels
for a reason for no reason at all
um and uh so
and i
ended up buying this one and i think it
misinterpreted the adjective graphic
it's actually not that graphic it's very
funny
and it's very it's very well done i
didn't actually i hadn't moved beyond
volume one
not because i don't want to because i
feel like i learned what i needed to
learn for the purposes that i was trying
to learn them what occasions sitting
down to enjoy
uh what's it called sex crimes sex
criminals volume
one weird trick
like
is this like a before bed reading is
this on your is this like
downstairs by the fireplace i don't do
any reading next to the fireplace that
only happens in movies man
i mean you've got a really great place
to do some uh
i bought it for research purposes
and um and i just read it i read i read
it in a couple of nights like a couple a
couple nights i was like okay
i don't know what you're trying to
research but you're not going to stop
time
by ejaculating i know i believe me i've
tried
uh well i i do recommend that i don't
know if that's gonna be my wreck i'm
gonna pick one of these things to be my
official wreck but uh that was sort of a
weird one that stood out when i was like
oh what did i oh i know why i bought
that and i bought a couple other ones
that are like really
well respected sort of like timeless
graphic novels that i actually
can't remember where they are at this
point nothing's been as good as watchmen
to me i'm i'm i'm a normie when it comes
to
graphic novels so huh
can i borrow it yeah sure
just put it under your mattress
[Music]
like when trent gave me that penthouse
what am i going for next i'm going to go
with my biggest purchase of the year
oh well i think yeah my next purchase
ties in with that so you go ahead and uh
no no i don't think it does my mountain
bike oh i got a new
i mean this is what i mean this is
probably this might be my biggest
purchase since i've got a car sure has
to be because um
you know one of the main things that i
i got back into
your before last
what was my mountain biking you know i
i'd fallen out of it
nick and i would go mountain biking a
lot and then it was just like things got
busy and it's kind of like surfing for
us it's just like uh you know it
requires like some logistics umph to get
going with it
and i got back into it and he got a new
bike like he upgraded
uh
to a full suspension bike instead of
just the front suspension and it like
had his head a fan has a fancy spring in
it and then he's talking about how much
better it is
when you know he's got the uh adjustable
seat post
where it's like you just hit the button
and it it adjusts up and down yeah
um and he's like talking about
how much more of an advantage he has
when going downhill with center of
gravity being able to be lower and here
i am every time we're about to do a big
climb
i'm getting off my bike and i'm putting
my seat up high
to get you know because you want to you
want to climb with your seat high and
then you want to then when we're about
to go down a hill the riding was on the
wall it's like he's about he there he
goes and i'm getting off my bike and
putting my seat post all the way down so
that my center of gravity is lower and
i'm not going over my handle bars right
and i'm like you know what for my
birthday i'm gonna i'm gonna upgrade and
you know
feed
thousands and thousands like you know
over five thousand dollars for a bicycle
it seems like madness but if you want
one that is gonna i mean this is like
your life is in this is some there's a
lot of engineering that goes into this
it's pretty amazing you can't really get
away
you can't especially if you're going
with someone who has that type of
equipment right who's made that
investment the all the things that he
was telling me he was like he was
selling me on it and it it took a long
time
and then with all the supply chain
things that were happening and continue
to happen
i had my eye on a bike
that was you not even available for
pre-order
and but it was the one that i wanted and
it was just like okay in three weeks you
sign up for the mailing list we'll tell
you in three weeks when this thing's
gonna become available
and then at three weeks it's like three
more weeks and then this happens for
like three four months yeah and then one
day we're riding and i'm just kind of
and i'm telling him this and he's like
dude there's a bike shop right over here
and they got some in stock
and i'm like it's funny how i just like
i just like i just cringe inside i'm
like oh no you mean we're gonna go
somewhere right now and i'm gonna i'm
gonna drop
six grand on a bike just right there
it's like this is this goes against
every fiber of my bean
but
i hadn't
made a decision that i was gonna get a
bike i'd picked it out and i so i had
i'd spent the money in my mind
so it kind of helped me and i went there
and i was like you know what i'm never
going to get that other one so i i ended
up getting a specialized bike and you
get to that
yeah i get to actually ride it i'd
probably still be waiting
for the other one
uh from canyon
so i got to specialize it's got the the
tube at the bottom is a little bit
bigger and it has a secret compartment
in it where instead of like having to
buy this an accessory that go under your
bike seat to hold like
your other bike tubes and all that crap
that you need if something goes wrong
uh all of that stuff can be hidden
inside of the bike itself yeah so i that
was cool
and that got me a little bit excited it
better be cool i'm telling you but um so
i got that thing
and
i've really been enjoying it
so it's
like it's made a huge difference having
the full suspension like i've never
dropped that money and then not then my
immediate experience was not
just regret
like with all of the psychology of me
spending money like that was one that
like
i've been so happy with it in the past
six days i've gone out every other day
on like a pretty long ride just by
yourself uh yeah i'll try to go out
i've got a shorter route that i can do
and like from door to i can i can be
from my house and back in like an hour
and ten so i can do like a 45 minute
ride and then i've got a a good local
ride
that's
like two hours
that i can do
so it's like
an hour and a half
climb
and then then it's a really long
uh
you know 40 minute descent back down
and
but then what happens is
there's a lot it that necessitates a lot
of other purchases
because you start going a little faster
and you've got more performance and
you've got
uh you start pushing yourself and i so i
start falling off my bike more so you
get ointments and
yeah i got bandages well protective gear
so like
and i got knee pads
i've got elbow pads
and
um i've and i've still got all these
bruises on my thighs and i fell off die
pads i fell off a few days ago and i hit
my hip and so now the last thing i
bought was
padded underwear so i'm trying that any
one of those airbags that this if you
fall off the whole thing just inflates
you become the michelin man just roll
down the mountain i mean these mountains
that i'm on it's like i mean there's
it it's treacherous
a one wrong move and i and i'm not
telling chris do this but yeah i could
just careen off the mountain and die
yeah i in that you know my but i'm
pretty good i i enjoyed and i'm liking a
little bit like
right when when when nick was getting
into it back in the day yeah and then
like the three of us went out just a
couple of times i there was like
one time i was coming down the hill and
i was like
the whole time i feel like i'm going to
go over the top of the handlebars
and i look around at everyone else doing
this and i'm like no one is as big as me
and i was like it's tough i'm i'm you
know what i'm this is something i'm
going to have to just say no to because
i yeah places
i'm too worried about my
uh our
at times more intense than the stuff we
do now because we had no business being
in some of those places we were
especially on the bikes we were on my
bike's like 15 years old 20 years ago
so
i mean so i got the protective gear and
then i'm like pushing myself and coming
back
and i'm having these headaches that i
can't get rid of and i'm realizing i'm
burning so much so many calories that
i'm not eating enough and like so it
like leads to like figuring all this
stuff out to like optimization type
stuff but then also realizing oh i gotta
be
i can't just be drinking water i gotta
be drinking some electrolytes
so i start buying
uh
the tim ferriss sponsored ellen element
salty stuff you can get all types it's
not a sponsor of ours but like so now i
put up a packet of that into my i've
gotten to a point now
where
if i do a really like a two hour ride or
i push it
i'm i'm either barely or not getting a
headache between like
calories afterward and like
drinking enough electrolytes i think
but it's not fueling yourself enough i'm
kind of for the first time it's kind of
got me to a point where i'm feeling
almost athletic almost athletic i'm you
know i've never considered myself an
athlete
but like i think this is so there's old
there's older guys out on these trails
and i think this could be me i think
this could be a long-term version of
golf for me as long as i don't kill
myself doing it you're not going to die
golfing that's for sure but i kind of
feel like
i could be
in the best shape of my life if i keep
this up
because i it's a because i actually
enjoy it
like i've never done anything that's
pushed my body so hard that i've
actually liked because i mean there's a
physical challenge of it but then
there's i mean there's the
there's the mental acuity of just the
just the constant
uh
reacting to the trail
you know you're and i so i think it's
good for my
brain and my body
and i feel and i feel like
i'm doing something that requires a lot
of padding
and that kind of makes me feel a little
bit cool you could probably like slip
into like a intramural football game
i think i was dressed weird but
what position does he play so so a lot
of crap related to that bite well okay
you this is related to a purchase that
you made which uh
this was unusual because a lot of times
i'll decide to buy something that's
right that then you'll
get into and and then this would work
the other way
so the purchase that i have related to
this again because i'm limiting mine to
amazon
is uh
wrist guards with palm protection
um
and this is when we this is a sore
subject let's go ahead and we got uh the
one wheels you know i think we've talked
about the one the one wheels you know
it's that thing that looks like a
skateboard but it's got one big wheel in
the middle it's the electric
so it's
i mean it's
pretty pretty damn cool because it's it
it kind of works like
it's the i have to think it's the
technology of uh what are those
the the trendy things that
the air airboards it works like a segway
for lack of a better i mean it's it it's
essentially the wheel itself is a thing
that is both propelling you
and holding you up and balancing you and
it has regenerative charging yeah
and
i mean and on the website when you look
at this thing you're like you can go on
track you can go on dirt trails it's not
just for
for pavement and and some of the most
fun that we've i mean so we got you got
three of them right no i got two of them
i got two because i kept seeing these
instagram ads for them yeah and i was
like i'm trying to get the boys out of
the house and like i couldn't i haven't
had luck getting them to ride bikes that
much with me because i end up pushing
things a little too far and then they're
just
dejected
and spent
so that didn't take and i was like this
will be fun yeah and it's it's not
you're not you're not really working too
hard on this there's just some balancing
happening but it's not dangerous once
you learn how to do it i mean we're not
going to be going off on these trails
but i kind of secretly hope we'll be
going off on these trails right and so
then i'm like
i get it and then i invite you and
shepherd over to test it out
and like shepherd immediately took to it
so then you're like well i'm gonna get a
couple of these too so like yeah i had
the pint for lando which is a smaller
one and then the gt for me the bigger
one well the xr the xr yeah and then you
you bought two xrs right for uh i mean
they're not
they're not cheap it was like seventeen
hundred dollars for for an xr and maybe
1200 for uh maybe more for a pint
they're one of the more more pricier
like
evs
but
i i gotta say
you know it's same thing with shepard
it's not easy to get shepherd
outside of the house away from video
games
but any time i'm like hey let's go one
wheel and he's like all right drops what
he's doing and we go
and we have gotten
like we have found so many cool places
to go where the majority of what we're
doing is off-road and i've had some
close calls
i posted that one on my instagram where
i fell and messed my knee up it actually
wasn't that bad it was the worst fall
that i've had because i actually fell
well it was interesting i think even
before that happened like
i was writing you came over and then you
got him and you started writing and then
you start telling me about how
the type of injuries you can get on this
stuff and like how
the dangers associated with it and i
didn't i had not looked into any of that
i was like well you know we're just
going to be safe well the nose diving is
the nose diving is the thing that like
if you start looking on youtube
everyone's got a story about well i
broke my collarbone i think like casey
neistat broke his collarbone or broke
something
doing because what happens is you if
you're comfortable you get going real
fast and then it gets to a certain speed
you can go 17 to 20 miles an hour and
then it starts it pushes back a little
bit to tell you hey we can't keep
holding you up at this speed
but if you ignore that it'll nose dive
and then you immediately just careen off
of the thing so i kind of stay away from
that
top speed yeah you have to learn it you
have to learn the limits of it and
you have to you have to wear protective
gear if you're gonna be that was one
thing is that especially the wrist
guards because the one time i did fall
on the pavement i did nose dive but it's
only because i just i'm i'm so big and
i'm like kind of at the upper weight
limit
and i was going up a hill as fast as i
possibly could but it didn't feel fast
to me it was just and i also couldn't
feel the push back and nose dived
or nose dove whatever the proper uh term
is
and i fell and caught myself with my
wrist guards and it like skinned them up
real bad i was like man that would have
been real bad if i hadn't
had these wrist guards but that's what
happened which which brings me you never
bought any wrist guards but i i had to
borrow your uh
your xr for lincoln
so that lando could ride the pint and he
and i would each have one and so i also
took your wrist guards that day
and then
of course they were always wearing
helmets and i had elbow pads and knee
pads from mountain biking that i put on
the put on the boys
lincoln had fallen and hurting his hurt
his elbow
without pads so i was like you got to
wear the pads from now on
and then i saw the wrist guards and
lando was over there somewhere i told
this story on good mythical more
and so i was like well
i got this pair of wrist guards lincoln
put these on
well
turns out i put the only pair of risk
guards that i borrowed from you on the
wrong kid yeah
and uh
yeah lando we were going off-road
and lana was getting pretty good at it
and then he just got tossed
i saw it all happen
and um
he he said he hurt his wrist
and i said you know just like
just wait a little bit and we'll walk
back wave it off and then um
we took the dogs for a walk later he
didn't seem like he was complaining too
much we i took him out to dinner later
he said he was having trouble using his
hand to get the food on his fork yeah he
was having to use the other hand and
then his mom came home from whatever she
was at
late after lando was in bed
his mom your wife yeah
and then the next morning uh we wake up
to lando
by the bed
telling
his mom
how much his wrist hurts
and and i didn't tell her anything had
happened
so that's how she found out that uh and
she was like well you need to take him
to urgent care and give him get him an
x-ray which i did
and
when the nurse came back in i was
i was pretty you know i get nauseous and
uncomfortable about potential
breaks and talk of circulation and
things of that nature talk of
circulation so when the nurse
is pretty broad comes in and says uh
yeah
we took a look at the x-ray
and um
his wrist is just above his wrist it is
clean in two and i started laughing yeah
like every good father would but it was
because i was so uncomfortable that's
i just like i can't i just that's just
the noise that comes out of me
and uh i didn't remember this but what
lando told me
afterward when he also told
christy uh his mom yeah said that um
you know that the nurse said sir um
this is a serious issue yeah this is not
a laughing matter
and i was i was laughing i don't like
talk of circulation i was laughing so
much
and uncomfortable that i didn't even
hear her say that i just kept kind of
giggling
so yeah he had a broken wrist and at
this point he's not he's still not
released by the doctor to get back on
the one wheel but when he does he's got
wrist guards so he didn't go the other
day it's just you and lincoln yeah
uh me and shepard went the other day it
had like the best time that we love it
lincoln and i had the best time going to
the same place well and then
going on like sandy trails off-road and
like especially when you've got like the
proper protection wrist guards elbow
guards knee pads helmet for me you have
confidence the great thing about the uh
the off-roading is you don't get as fast
as you do on the pavement so i actually
feel like i fall a whole lot more
i fall i just fall off and then i just
kind of run it out
whereas when i'm on payment i get so
fast i'm like if i fall right now it's
gonna be on pavement and it's gonna be
bad
uh and then the funny thing is is you've
actually i think you've changed quite a
bit because you know i saw the
advertisements for the new for the new
ones the gt and the the pint
the new pint
and it was like this new one the gt has
more torque more power i'm like that's
what i need oh it has a treaded tire
that you can get that's what i need
because i get on those trails and i'm
just i get to these hills that don't
seem that steep and shepherd you know
weighs half as much as me he just goes
right up i get on him and it just
bottoms out like it can't it can't
support me i'm too big and so
and then i tell you about you're like oh
you already bought one i got one comment
i'm like what this man has gotten so
loose with his cash listen yeah i blame
myself for the for the accidents that my
kids have had
and i because i i i'm getting another
one this is fine
well and then and then what and i was
like okay well i got to get one now so i
got one of those on the way we're
actually getting them on orders
we're gonna have six of those things
we're going to like find a friend to
just come along well the app
the app will tell you if other people in
your neighborhood have it you can meet
up with strangers in one way i don't
know if i want to do that okay let me
rattle off a few quick ones here um
i got the rhapsodo mobile launch monitor
which is a way to keep up with how uh
far your golf ball will go and all you
have to do is hit it into a net and it's
reading the speed of the golf ball and
figuring out like oh you hit a six iron
this far oh it doesn't say oh you just
hit it three foot into a net yeah it
tells you how far it would have gone uh
i gotta say i've had to back off of the
i haven't i purposely haven't swung a
golf club in about two months because i
was convinced that it was causing my
shoulder
problem and unfortunately i think i was
right
so i don't know i'm having to
re-evaluate my long-term future oh you
should get in a mountain bike what am i
going to do it's like if i'm hurting
myself golfing what am i going to do
next mountain biking um this is a this
is you know what this is going to be my
recommendation the baseball
cap
carrier case
okay you're like what do you need one of
those okay so i was going is this what
it sounds like it is it's a plastic case
it's a way to put
baseball hats in your luggage and not
have to worry about like packing them
perfectly so that they get messed up
when i was going back to north carolina
over the summer i was gonna be playing
golf a few times with my dad and my
brother and i and i wear a hat when i
when i'm out in the sun like that and
you don't want it to be crinkled but i
don't want to like i don't like having
to then wear the hat on the plane and
and also there was like a couple of hats
that i had and i found this thing on
amazon the baseball cap carrier case and
i'm like this thing's perfect holds like
three or four baseball hats and you just
put it in your luggage and you can't you
i mean you can see hollow under the back
so you can still nest it on something or
does it take up a lot of room uh
you know it takes up the room of a of a
stack of hats it doesn't it it doesn't
come in and
but where your head goes into the hat is
that hollowed out
it's flat it's the whole bottom is flat
burnt i'm out which makes it easier it
makes it easier to pack
in something but it takes up more space
well i mean maybe you can make one of
those maybe one of those exists i want
to make one of those in the in the
world's best garden hose okay i've got
two items that i bought because i have a
17 year old son i have one more by the
way oh yeah one more yeah okay well i've
got like i mean i i wanna i i've got
i got a few
and i wanna i'm gonna i'm just gonna
rattle through so if you wanna save
yours for the to be the last thing okay
um you have this too by the way okay
well then there you go save it for the
end we'll be happy happy and it will be
united in in our purchase i share okay i
share the blender with everyone but the
people who use the blender in my house
it's me and lock to make these protein
shakes that we make and he doesn't clean
up after himself
and so he'll leave like some dirty once
you leave that that blender bottle out a
few times without cleaning it yep it
gets cloudy and nasty and you'll never
get rid of it
right and so what i decided to do is i
was like i'm going to buy a replacement
carafe essentially but i'm going to use
that one and you're going to keep using
the crappy one and you can do whatever
you want to it oh so now i have this
blendtec
carafe you've which you've hidden that i
just i keep it on the top shelf inside a
cabinet and i literally i use it i make
my smoothie i wash it out immediately
immediately put it back up there it's i
can you you could use it as glasses it's
so clear compared to the other one that
looks like it's painted this is a 17 and
then i'm picking you reading through a
picture what are you doing are you
looking at that blendtec carafe no i'm
reading
uh and i also got a three pack of extra
large shaker bottles congratulations you
know what i'm saying because again same
thing he uses my shaker bottle
and i've got one that's like the green
one's mine
i'll be like where's my damn
shaker bottle i don't know what you mean
it's like making what it's like if you
it's what you if you wanted to put a
protein shake without using the blender
oh but we just it's what we put we will
shake like pre-workout or something in
there but we also okay just put the
shakes in there and you know how i mean
this is typical dad but like you go
downstairs and you make your smoothie
and then you look for your and then
immediately i just flip out right
because i'm just like
i know he took my damn bottle and you
know it's like it's just one of those
things you gotta have your own and so i
go up there and it's in his room and
it's got crap in it and it smells like
something died inside of it meaty it's
very meaty
and so i bought a three pack and i was
like you can't touch any of these
i have three just in case you end up
touching one i got two more behind it
um i bought this and i did this several
times
lightning cable three foot three pack oh
good luck with that and usb wall charger
with three inputs on it yep yep i don't
know how many of these
someone
someone is taking them and making like
spaghetti out of them somewhere in our
home
because i was like can't we just have
like i want one kind of like oh here's a
charger you're moving towards just
having your own house
yeah yeah
yeah that's i've thought of this
and then you've got it like there's one
that's like behind the couch and it has
an extra long cable so that like hey i'm
watching tv and my phone's about to die
plug it in set it down
here's one downstairs in the gym where
we're working out here's one in the
kitchen just
i had it all figured out they end up
taking them and they just you know i
have to just keep buying them i don't
know what i'm going to do about that i
haven't solved that other than just
buying stuff
this is one uh i i'll spend a second on
uh i bought some tifas
i noticed that
i talked to christy about it yeah
because she has them i was like is this
a thing
well what now first of all somebody said
that you're supposed to say tevas
i don't care i'm gonna say tevis because
that's what i've always said
so
it's the wearing it this
this is very funny that you're bringing
this up because we haven't talked about
this
so
i i can't remember where i was i think
it was when we were in key west and i
like had my flip-flops and i'm thinking
about the fact that we're probably we're
going to uh we're going to spend some
time in mexico over the holidays and uh
having like a shoe that you can wear
when you're like we're going and doing
some like outdoor activities and i don't
want to wear those like water shoes that
are like closed-toed that we had you
remember like the ones that we had in
every everybody got when we went to fiji
i think you're talking about keens which
are like the rei version of a water shoe
they're in like like cl clothes
i know what you're talking about i'm
talking about the ones that are more
like sock-like oh well that of course
not that's like and so i was like and
and so i have a bias again dumb child at
a wave pool
i have a bias against sandals that are
not flip-flops okay i don't like
jessie's like you need to get some
barking socks that's like i don't like
the way birkenstocks look and she was
like well you get some tv's i was like i
hate the way tevas look like i i've
never seen somebody in tevas
birkenstocks are like hippie
but tevas are like
granola right but here's the thing
i have a bias against them
and i told jesse i was like
if i went if i get these and i wear
these around link it'll be the first
thing he talks about when he sees me
it's funny because
there's a there's a clip going around
about uh that was an interview with
larry david from like years ago oh yeah
the one where seinfeld says when he
walks in the room and he's gonna talk
about your shirt and me and you have
that kind of thing we've judged
everything that you could possibly wear
and we've come to a bunch of conclusions
about them yeah and so i think that tv's
looked dorky right i can't i cannot i
think they look dorky on me i cannot get
whether you got socks on or not
but i put them on and jesse's like you
don't understand
they're not dorky anymore and if they
are that's what makes them cool right
and so she's basically telling me this
i put these tivas on one night we go to
pasadena you went out to go eat and i'm
well and i'm walking around in these
things and i've also got on like
some like these cotton pants they're
like a drawstring kind of thing i feel
stupid the whole time but i'm feeling
great like i i feel like i look stupid
but i'm like
i keep leaning over her i'm like i think
i might be a tiva guy like these are
incredible like the fact that they don't
flop they feel so secure but my feet are
breathing i'm like i kind of think that
regardless of how these things look
maybe i'm just a tiva guy now damn
christy wore these at disneyland both
days and here i am taking off my shoes
and socks in a public place oh it's
revolutionary and i was like are the
straps kidding you is the no no no feet
are great there's nothing it feels so
good the whole time i go into a coffee
shop jesse's like let's get a couple of
decafs i'm like i'll go in
i go in i go out to the counter this is
some random coffee shop on colorado and
in pasadena
in the in the barista says
hey
you look like you're from colorado
you literally said that yeah yeah
yes he did i mean the hair the beard
yeah yeah yeah and like and antivas and
so i was like yes the tv is red i was
like
thank you
i'm gonna go took that as a compliment
she says i love colorado
um but i gotta say i'm not from colorado
i just listened to my wife i gotta say
that you're going to be seeing the tivas
more often and i think that there is a
way to for to transcend in my mind and
like it i'm i'm kind of getting through
this sort of like there's this sort of
like guys from the south
kind of bias that we have against we we
think tiva's strapping we're thinking
about those tivas in a certain way that
i'm just trying to let go of but me and
you i now when we used to wear
flip-flops with jeans all the time like
on television like commercial kings we'd
be walking around
with no
yeah and also like i know we did looking
for miss locklear yeah we're walking
around with flip-flops and jeans and
it's like it looks horrible that looked
horrible yeah we did it we thought it
was cool it's kind of an anti-climactic
ending down there
but yeah there needs to be something
substantial when i looked at you the
only time i saw you wearing them you
were in loungewear at your own home and
i said you know what
i'm not going to judge a man for what he
wears in his own home i believe i had it
going so i didn't bring it up
but you thought about it i thought about
them but that's what i thought i'm not
going to judge a man in his own home
you know
but it's like
i don't know what he's
i don't know what i don't know where
this is going i might be changing my
wreck to tivas and tevas if that's how
you say it and you know what does it uh
i mean after the disneyland airing out
situation yeah christie having a so are
you but now
we also have this thing that's like if
you have a thing
now i can't that can't be my thing is it
your thing and now i can't do are you
boxing me out
i got the tivas before you
christie got him before maybe you get to
you i mean my wife was really pushing
birkenstocks and the only reason i
didn't do birkenstocks i i thought
birkenstocks were equally ugly i can't
do it i thought they were equally ugly
but they weren't comfortable to me the
tivas i feel like i could do anything
do anything
am i in and i've got this platform on my
feet
okay
we're running we're about to run out of
time we actually have some place to be
but i have to say
the continuous water mister
this is another graphic novel
yeah this is the follow-up to sex
criminals
no it's that thing we actually have one
here but i ended up getting one at home
mr continuous water it's it's what i
spray on my hair to get it to bounce
back and for the curl to come back a lot
of people are asking what what do you do
well i mean you just spray it with a
little bit of water continue what
doesn't work is wetting your hair the
mister and you know what you get you'll
be like i need to hit my face with this
why i just hit your face with it it's
like you know how when you go to the
park when it's really hot and you walk
by one of those misters you have one in
your hand
i highly recommend that put any water in
it any water yeah you fill it up with
you can use tap water i if if we have
distilled water on hand i'll use that
okay but it's refillable uh and the last
thing i'm actually skipping over some
stuff just just to spare you the last
thing i'll say
we also have this here but i don't know
what i would do without it at home
the downy wrinkle releaser the only
reason i'm talking about this is because
i other other day uh and we're in the
wardrobe
wardrobe room and getting ready for gmm
and uh stevie walks in to ask us
something and i'm like spraying
this thing directly on my clothes and
she looks at me and she's wearing this
shirt on and she's
you're spraying yourself with febreze
no it's not that bad
she didn't know about the wrinkle
release and so i just feel like i have
to tell the world that
there's this spray that if you're if
your shirt's a little bit wrinkly and
you don't want to steam it and you don't
want to iron it how it works you just
spray it lightly on it and it just those
wrinkles go away you gotta you can get
travel size
you know these people who breaking out
the ironing board in your hotel room
i'm here in my tevas just spraying
myself with water on my hair and wrinkle
release on my clothes i'm from colorado
huh
see but you're i mean we're both we're
plaid boys today
neither one of us is their it's their
thing it's not yours i think you could
also wear tevas yeah i think there's
definitely multiple situations there's
probably whole tiva families at disney
that you just didn't you weren't
thinking about it
i wasn't
um the last thing i was gonna mention
was the aura ring
i know you used to yeah i i didn't buy a
lot of crap but that was a that was a
big thing that uh
in full disclosure
we uh we
we invested in our ring after after
buying it independently and being
satisfied with it well you got this
because you the nba players were wearing
it and monitoring their heart rate and
their health and stuff and all the covet
of it all but then it's just like all
the biometric measurements in the in
this ring are
um
they're more in depth and more accurate
than
the biometrics on my watch that i also
still enjoy
and wear because it
and um
you can also try i think pico also got
one you got the oil ring you like it
yeah we're investors
uh yeah we i just i just ordered the uh
the next generation which constantly
monitors your uh your heart rate
uh not just while you're sleeping but i
love the way that it connects with the
app and it like it tells you what your
readiness is and it kind of gives you
permission to take it easy if you need
to well that will tell you
that it kind of trans again you can do
the reason
that i love it is that
you basically last like a week on a
charge whereas
i i wear the apple watch quite a bit but
like i'll get ready to go to bed i'm
like oh man i gotta charge this thing
and then so yeah i mean technically four
to seven days the ring will hold a
charge and you need to charge it during
the day
so that you can wear it while you're
sleeping but it also charges in like 30
minutes yeah it's super fast yeah it
charges but like i used it this past
week when i'm i'm trying to
make sure like having something tell you
that you got all the sleep that you
needed
and that this was the nature of your
sleep yeah
for me it gave me this like
um
assurance that like okay yes you're
doing all you can to keep from getting
sick as your family drops like flies the
way that it works with the app and the
way that communicates with you and
optimizes
your uh your exertions and your your
resting
is uh i would say much more holistic
than than with the watches your question
about
um the tivas i mean i think
two guys who are best friends who both
have a ring on their right hand
that looks pretty similar we have
different models but essentially just
like i think that that's probably more
like
those guys both have rings now if we had
the rings and the tivas at the same time
and the plaid and the plaid i mean the
beard there's a there's a i mean listen
i i'm heading towards here's the deal
i'm not going to get rid of the beard i
can't
you're eventually going to grow a beard
i mean you're at some point right yeah
we know where this is i'm gonna get
glasses at some point i mean we're
becoming one person it's gonna happen we
fought it and we're no longer caring so
it is actually going to happen
yeah
so that's all that's that's all the
stuff that i bought and some of the
stuff that christy bought that i took
credit for and that's a third of the
stuff that you bought yeah
not even a third that was probably a
tenth but it was it was just
inconsequential like spirulina you know
i i didn't mention that that was one you
know got some of that got a whole bag of
it
okay
hashtag your biscuits let us know what
you think about what we bought
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best